[Musik]
in einer woche beginnen hier nahe der
stadt sotschi die olympischen
winterspiele
[Musik]
ein modernes und gereinigtes russland
soll die welt sehen
doch kann das land hier kaukasus seine
schwächen nicht verbergen
eine gratwanderung
auch für die drei menschen in unserem
film
[Musik]
bruno jelk der erfahrene
bergrettungschef und zimmert com letzten
winter als berater für den dienst doch
sotschi
[Musik]
er sagt die wetterkapriolen dieses
subtropischen gebirgszuges seien ein
großes risiko für die alpinen
wettbewerbe
die siegerin alexandra diana war ist
eine professionelle rodler
zweimal war sie schon an olympischen
spielen dabei mit 30 jahren ist sie die
älteste im team sechs fahrerinnen
kämpfen um drei plätze für sotschi und
jonas größter traum der olympiasieg im
eigenen land
[Musik]
für viele frauen in meinem alter ist es
das größte liebens ziel kinder zu haben
bei mir ist es noch nicht so weit weil
ich diesen sieg noch nicht errungen habe
darum sage ich immer wartet noch kinder
wartet ich will das hier zuerst zu ende
bringen
[Musik]
die russische krisenregion da gestern
hier herrschen arbeitslosigkeit
und bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände
tausende von männern zieht es darum auf
die baustellen von solchen
[Musik]
auch magomed cassano wie sich auf die
reise machen für die arbeit in der
olympiastadt daher gerüstet
ich bin ein guter bauarbeiter fahrer
musikant und säufer
wir tun
alexandra die order war steht unter
großem druck die alle russischen
athletinnen und athleten
sportliche siege haben im heutigen
russland fast wieder den gleichen
stellenwert wie zu sowjetzeiten
wir spüren alle dass wir kein recht
haben schlechte leistungen zu zeigen die
olympischen spiele in turin oder
vancouver waren halt im ausland klar
wird man dort auch das beste aber es ist
eine innere ruhe da hier ist das ganz
anders hier gibt man dir keine chance
hier musst du einfach gute leistungen
zeigen
für den erfolg gibt russland sehr viel
geld aus
diese bob und rodelbahn außerhalb
moskaus hat fast 50 millionen franken
gekostet
eröffnet wurde sie 2008 vom damaligen
präsidenten
medwedew
heute wird sie aber nicht mehr benutzt
sie sei zu gefährlich sagen die athleten
immerhin die startbahn funktioniert noch
es ist spätsommer
trainer martin hillebrand aus
deutschland hat er 30 jahre lang
deutsche rodler zu olympiasiegern
gemacht die russen verpflichten seit
jahren internationale spitzentrainer für
die winter disziplinen beim rodeln
wollen sie die deutschen athleten vom
spitzenplatz verdrängen
goldmedaillen in sotschi werden von
regional und den russischen roth lang
gefordert doch davon ist das ganze team
weit entfernt die resultate ernüchternd
persönlich bin ich nicht zufrieden
absolut nicht
ich wollte eigentlich mehr erreichen ich
wollte mehr bewegen
ich habe sehr viel investiert auch ein
technologie technik transfer und
know-how-transfer und ich sehe was
eigentlich jetzt unter dem strich
herauskommt es ist nicht mehr viel zeit
es sind nur noch ein paar monate
ist es für mich zu wenig ich komme aus
dem team das sind absolut ein wiener
team der besten allen olympischen
disziplinen eine geschichte kann man
sagen und das war einfach wesentlich
punktuelle genauer präzise gearbeitet
wie sehr der rubel rollt den schnellen
erfolg kann er nicht garantieren auch
nicht mit den besten trainern der welt
sagte
gegenüber den deutschen deutschen
mannschaft wo man versucht haben sechs
ausgefuchste tränen oder jeden seinen
kompetenzbereich hundertprozentig
arbeiten und hier sind es vielleicht nur
die proben aus dem ausland auch sehen
und die müssen dann wieder
zusammenarbeiten und diese ganze
abstimmung
das öffentliche interesse im vorfeld der
spiel ist riesig auch die politik mischt
mit selbst präsident wladimir putin war
schon im training zu gast
da kann die konzentration aufs
wesentliche schon mal wegfallen
glück für
die ganze welt
der rosa peak die bergstation der
olympischen abfahrt pisten auf 2300
meter über meer
es ist winter saison
2013 die zeit der testrennen oft müssen
sie verschoben werden schlechtes wetter
und lawinengefahr
die nähe zum meer kann dir sehr viel
regen und thermalen brüche bringen aber
jederzeit auch riesige schneemassen
lawinen auf der olympia piste
am renntag wäre das eine blamage
[Musik]
zu wenig nicht sogar eine tussi und
netzfehler und der
grubenwehr netzstruktur der die fische
schlawiner zeichnet für die ufc die
piste wenn wir das schlag blauen bericht
dass er wohl so lanz gar nicht anders
möglich weil sich das skigebiet jeden
gemacht hätte ich das nicht anders mit
lichtenberg
anzeigen wo bist du auch einmal für
besitzer gewechselt und die low nach
einer positiv auf die piste gehen und
hauptsächlich auf den fortbestand der
türe zum
entspringt gereicht haben deshalb ist
das heißt eine gerbung wettkampf ist das
netz wieder neu stellen und schnee boomt
olympische spiele in subtropischen
gebirge das kommt sogar den
einheimischen lawinenschutz mitarbeitern
mitunter respekt vor sie haben hier ihre
eigene theorie warum präsident wladimir
putin diese spiele gerade in sotschi
haben wollte
und hatte damals niemand gefragt ob wir
diese spiele wollen oder nicht
putin kam erstmals ende der 90er jahre
hierher er und seine leute wollten
damals einen ferienort gründen haben
dann aber gesehen dass hier das land
schon vergeben ist dann haben sie die
olympischen spiele organisiert und ob
alles an sich gerissen
nun das ist natürlich meine persönliche
meinung
gasexplosionen zur künstlichen auslösung
von lawinen in sotschi haben die
verantwortlichen schließlich dieses
system gewählt dass lawinen institut von
davos das beratend zur seite stand wie
zusätzlich zu den er mit sprengungen
die damit wäre bei den vielen rechten
und kurzen steilen hängen effizienter
[Musik]
aber der russische geheimdienst fsb
legte sein veto ein
wir sind ja nahe beim heißen
nordkaukasus das heißt terrorismus da
wären dynamit und sprengstoff für
gewisse herren eine katastrophe kaum
auszudenken was geschehen würde wenn die
nicht hier mit dynamit in der tasche
erwischen
abends schreibt bruno jelk berichte und
empfehlungen die dann übersetzt und nach
moskau geschickt werden
und hier haben
[Musik]
für bruno jelk den gewissenhaften
zermatt rettungschef ist das hier eine
ganz besondere situation
erst nur als berater hier ohne
verantwortung zu tragen er sei froh
darüber denn oben am olympiaberg seien
die hierarchien unklar
die andere ist
dass sie sich keine show informiert er
kriegt berliner informiert und diesmal
haben wir uns zwei mal wieder daran dass
er damit gleich stehen der fcz macht und
der dreht am internet unterwegs macht
das geht nicht das muss ich noch so gar
nicht ganz und wirkt verantwortlich hier
das kann jeder
der wintersportort rosaroter wo der
zermatter heck untergebracht ist wurde
erst vor kurzem eröffnet
nach der olympiade sehen wie das
weitergeht
schnitt zur gut tue
und mit 100 jahre
die kraft
sie sei die größte baustelle der welt
rühmen sich die olympia organisatoren
in wenigen jahren stampft die russen
hier vier neue ski orte aus dem boden
und sämtliche anlagen für die
winterspiele
[Musik]
eigentlich hatte die regierung zu beginn
gesetze erlassen die die korruption
einschränken sollten aber durchgesetzt
wurden sie von den behörden nicht
[Musik]
wieso dieser mann dem polizisten einen
geldschein in die hand drücken musste
wissen wir nicht aber die korruption hat
laut russischen wirtschaftsexperten in
sotschi zu einer kostenexplosion geführt
die meisten sport objekte sind ein
mehrfaches teurer als bei früheren
spielen zwischen 25 und 50 prozent der
investierten 50 milliarden soll im
korruptionssumpf versichert sein
die baustellen von sotschi haben
zehntausende gastarbeiter angelockt
harten arbeitsbedingungen und teils
niedrigen löhnen zum trotz reisten sie
aus der ganzen ehemaligen sowjetunion an
[Musik]
rund 800 kilometer östlich von sotschi
am anderen ende des kaukasus
er hat magomed kasan sein zuhause
[Musik]
im abgelegenen 500 seelen dorf de bug
ein dorf ohne kanalisation oder
gasanschluss mit schlechten straßen
[Musik]
vor ein paar jahren wurde dem dorf wegen
geldmangels auch noch die
gemeindeverwaltung geschlossen
schau dir mal diese sauerei an
keine verwaltung mehr
[Musik]
vor jahren hatten wir hier das beste
mehrzweck lokal der ganzen region
es gab musikanlagen und konzerte und
jetzt statt
im haus eines vorarbeiters wilm argument
die details für die reise nach sotschi
regeln
dieser hat aber schlechte neuigkeiten
aus moskau schicken sie nach wie vor
kein geld
wir können kein baumaterial kaufen jeden
tag sagen sie morgen morgen
argument muss warten
wir nutzen die zeit und lassen uns von
ihm da gestern zeigen bald merken wir
wie angespannt die lage in dieser
nachbarrepublik tschetscheniens ist
fast täglich berichten russische medien
dass man bei solchen einsätzen
vermeintliche terroristen und
islamistische rebellen getötet habe
pakistan ist eine wirtschaftliche krisen
regierung die gelder aus moskau landen
oft in den taschen der gruppen elite auf
dem markt wird zwar reichlich gehandelt
aber nachhaltige investitionen und
arbeitsplätze gibt es kaum
für späße sind sie hier durchaus zu
haben
134 kilo die ich nehmen wir aber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nur eine autostunde weiter wieder ein
terroranschlag wieder ein
selbstmordattentat
[Musik]
diesmal vor einem gerichtsgebäude
vier tote viele verletzte
die extremisten tragen den terror seit
jahren immer wieder auch in russische
städte nach moskau wurde erst kürzlich
nach wolgograd
brutale sicherheitskräfte gegen
extremistische aufständische eine
gewaltspirale im nordkaukasus allein
letztes jahr gab es über 500 tote der
blutigste konflikt europas
in der burg versammelt sich die männer
zum freitagsgebet wir praktizieren sie
den sufismus die für den kaukasus
traditionelle gemäßigte form des islam
die anhänger der radikaleren
salafistischen glaubensrichtung sieht
allerdings in form sie werden von den
sicherheitskräften verfolgt was wiederum
gegen gewalt provoziert
[Musik]
aber
aber die wurzel des problems sei nicht
die religion sondern das versagen des
staates klagt der imam
schauen sie sich doch unser dorf an die
jungen menschen haben hier nichts zu tun
es ist ein schweres leben würde man
wenigstens eine richtige straße bauen
und eine gasleitung ins dorf den rest
würden wir hier schon alleine schaffen
[Musik]
nicht einmal in der russischen armee
sind junge dagestanische männer mehr
erwünscht
[Musik]
hier auf dem dorfplatz haben sie aber
den großen traum ein eigenes skigebiet
dort hinter den hügeln gebe es einen
idealen ort
man müsste einfach eine straße bauen
dort gibt es steile pisten und flachen
pisten für alles bereit
zu fuß ist man in einer stunde dort im
moment gibt es dort aber noch nichts
wir müssen einfach nur in den westen
finden
der staat aber investiert in sotschi zum
beispiel 250 millionen franken für eine
neue bob und rodelbahn doppelt so teuer
wie ursprünglich geplant
dorthin unterwegs ist auch die
sibirische rodlerin alexander rodionowa
es ist november wichtige
qualifikationsrennen stehen an
[Musik]
nein
die jüngeren fahrerinnen machen radio
war mehr konkurrenz als erwartet sie
braucht unbedingt gute resultate
[Musik]
in der teaminternen wertung ist region
war derzeit nur auf dem vierten platz
das würde nicht reichen für die
winterspiele
wieder nichts nur ein vierter platz vom
olympiasieg kann derzeit keine rede sein
sogar die qualifikation ist in gefahr
und yonne war hat es fehle an der
feinabstimmung des schlittens
[Musik]
diese
sportminister witali mutko ist unter
druck vor vier jahren in vancouver
hatten die russischen athleten unter
seiner leitung das schlechteste ergebnis
aller zeiten erzielt und goldmedaillen
seiner rot lane sotschi scheint er
braucht diesmal nicht zu glauben
schade haben wir nicht noch ein jahr
mehr zeit zur vorbereitung dann würden
wir es hier allen zeigen nicht
natalia guard eine millionärin ist die
präsidentin des russischen rodel
verbandes junge witwe hat den posten und
eine große baufirma von ihrem tödlich
verunglückten man gern
die jungen russischen rodlerinnen nehmen
es leichter als team seniorin motto
weißt du zufrieden
trost findet alexandra war aber nur bei
ihrer trainerin aus der jugendzeit diese
wohnt 5000 kilometer entfernt in
alexandras sibirischer heimatstadt grad
was soll ich hier mit den trainer und
sprechen sie sagen dass sie alles
versuchen sie arbeiten am gestell und an
den kufen aber es hilft alles nichts sie
versprechen dass sie es weiter versuchen
es haben alle mühe
[Musik]
der zugang zum skigebiet von sotschi
bewacht werden flughafen
[Musik]
so schön kann der kaukasus ein
wenn das wetter einmal stimmt
für bruno jelk ist heute ein wichtiger
tag er hat eine große lawine übung
organisiert
versteht übrigens kein russisch
für die übung musste jährig an den
lawinen hang suchen der sicher ist eine
heikle aufgabe
es hat anderen ort bei solchen übungen
bereits unerwartet verschüttete und tote
gegeben
was du verstanden die sonne bewegen wenn
du probleme hast
diana die pr managerin der station ist
eine von mehreren vermeintlich
verschütteten sie wird mit einem
lawinensuchgerät
zwei meter tief vergraben
bei der bergstation machen sich
einheimische bahnangestellte und
alpinisten für den rettungseinsatz
bereit
im lawinen hang der obligate check mit
der vermeintlich verschütteten
[Musik]
tatjana melde dich mal per funk
problem
ja ich sehe noch etwas licht
dann lawinen
eine lawine ist runter acht menschen
werden vermisst
die rettung selber dürfen wir nach einem
jetzt der ferienorts leitung aus moskau
nicht mehr schämen
google filmt selber mit einer stirn
keiner die rettungsübung kann beginnen
ja aber da muss von dort kann die frau
nicht gut dass noch herausnehmen
und dann wieder die frage wie geht es
der verschütteten tatjana
mit dem radio kontrollieren wie es ihr
geht
[Musik]
japan kontrolliere ich den webangeboten
grünen die verstehen damit
[Musik]
schließlich finden die retter alle
lawinenopfer allerdings ziemlich spät
einmal mehr hat sich gezeigt die russen
können im echten notfall über sich
hinauswachsen übungen sind nicht zu ihre
sache
das dagestanische bergdorf die e book
vor rund 150 jahren hatten die truppen
des russischen zaren diese region und
dem ganzen nordkaukasus in brutalen
kriegen erobert
bis heute ist die beziehung zwischen
russen und in vielen klassischen
bergvölkern kompliziert
[Musik]
die kinder sprechen zwar alle eine der
vielen dagestanischen sprachen in der
schule aber ausschließlich russisch wir
dürfen an der literatur stunde beide
es geht um das antike olympia und darum
das zu jener zeit die waffen während den
spielen schwiegen
die sportlichen wettkämpfe nannte man
damals olympische spiele und sobald
diese spiele begannen hat man alle
kriege eingestellt
es wäre doch so gut wenn es jedes jahr
ein olympisches turnier gäbe
dann würden die menschen endlich kanonen
panzer und bomben ins meer werfen und es
gebe nie mehr krieg
und wo wurden die olympischen spiele der
antike durchgeführt in welcher stadt
nach sotschi ins gelobte land kann
endlich auch magomed aufbrechen
das geld aus moskau für baumaterial ist
inzwischen eingetroffen
zurück lässt er seinen schwer
behinderten bruder und seine mutter
[Musik]
mal
dann macht es sich auf die rund 1000
kilometer lange fahrt so wie es vor ihm
schon über zwei dutzend männer aus dem
kleinen dorf die ebook getan habt
[Musik]
es ist eine fahrt durch eine
hochsicherheitszone
[Musik]
aber es ist auch ein besonderer tag
tausende dagestanische fußballfans sind
unterwegs in die nachbarrepublik
tschetschenien
dort in der hauptstadt grosny steht ihr
team im russischen fußball pokalfinale
noch vor zehn jahren war grosny nach
zwei brutalen kriegen fast völlig
zerstört seither hat moskau milliarden
in den wiederaufbau investiert
der fußball soll normalität vermitteln
dass hier vieles nur fassade ist spüren
wir bald die sicherheits und
menschenrechtslage ist entertain in bis
heute prekär
[Musik]
es ist das erste pokalfinale auf
spanischem boden gut möglich dass das
eine politische botschaft im vorfeld der
olympischen spiele ist seht her im
kaukasus herrscht ruhe und festfreude
dokument wird sich dieses finalspiel im
modernen stadion auch nicht entgehen
lassen
[Musik]
weder der europäische noch der
weltfußballverband sind bereit hier
offizielle spiele zuzulassen warum mit
dem stadion schnell klar
[Musik]
eigentlich ist dieses finale die tribüne
für ramzan kadirow
republikchef und putins treuester
verbündeter im kaukasus
während kadir uspräsident schafft sind
politische oppositionelle und bekannte
menschenrechtler ermordet
manchmal sei bei folterungen persönlich
anwesend solche vorwürfe weist kadir auf
stets zurück der kreml lässt ihn
gewähren walka die rauft sich moskau
gegenüber loyal verhält
[Applaus]
im dagestanischen team von anschi
machatschkala standen letzte saison
millionen teure spieler im kader allen
voran der superstar samuel eto'o aus
kamerun
[Applaus]
gegner der dagestaner ist der armee klub
zska moskau
[Applaus]
moskauer fans kann man fast keine nach
grosny die zska klubleitung hat davon
abgeraten
der tk dierdorf fiebert mit seinem
pakistanischen nachbarn mit
[Applaus]
was uns auffällt kadir ups
sondereinsatztruppen in schwarz
gefürchtet unberechtigt in sotschi
sollen sie eine wichtige rolle im
sicherheitskonzept spielen
[Applaus]
für ein paar momente hoffen sie im
kaukasus auf einen sieg gegen die
moskauer
[Applaus]
dann entscheidet aber ein
elfmeterschießen und es ist seht du dumm
jahr 2010 noch torschützenkönig der
berner young boys der den hoffnung der
kaukasier ein ende setzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einmal mehr haben sie im kaukasus gegen
die moskauer verloren wie schon so oft
gesagt den kommunal kriegen vor 150
jahren
[Musik]
argument verabschiedet sich von kollegen
aus einem dorf die eher zufällig traf
[Musik]
natürlich hätten wir da bis da ja gerne
gewonnen was meinst du denn
man hat es gut in ihren gesichtern
gesehen
möge dich
das hier ist eine der dreckigsten städte
russlands die industriestadt in zentral
sibirien knapp 5000 km von sotschi
entfernt
ein penetranter gestank liegt in der
luft
[Musik]
hier ist die heimat der rodlerin
alexandra
weihnachtswoche in europa hat jana war
hat vier tage wurde
hier sieht noch meine ersten medaillen
und dort habe ich noch schnickschnack
aus der kindheit aufbewahrt
[Musik]
herzen habe ich gerne gesammelt
ich verstehe das nicht sie hat doch gut
ausgesehen als im sommer weg ging und
jetzt total dünn ist die geworden
aber jetzt werde sie vier tage
durchfüttern
anastasia die jüngere schwester
alexandras wohl bis heute in braz sie
hat eine siebenjährige tochter und ist
bereits zum zweiten mal schwanger
er selber habe mich nur im sport richtig
wohl gefühlt
in der schule habe ich bei allen
sportarten mitgemacht ich glaube sogar
ich habe sport gemacht weil ich wusste
dass ich damit eines tages von ihr
wegkommen
ach was damals hast du doch nicht ein
solches gedacht
natürlich habe ich das was meinst du
denn was uns die trainer damals gesagt
hatten in ihr gut trainiert könnt ihr
von hier weg und ins ausland reisen es
gibt euch neue perspektiven in anderen
sportarten oder so hätte ich diese
chance nie gehabt
[Applaus]
alexandra will unbedingt ihre nichte
milana von der schule abholen
[Musik]
mach dich bereit sie kommt gleich
mit
[Musik]
wie schon so oft nimmt alexandra ihre
nichte mit den stadtrand von bad
zur rodelbahn dort im ford knapp zwei
jahrzehnten ihre karriere begann
das eis handgemacht wie zu sowjetzeiten
automatische kühlungssysteme wie auf der
luxus bahn in sotschi kennt man hier
nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihr seid dabei dieses jahr ziemlich spät
dran ist die kinder bahn oben im betrieb
naja
mein junge was hast du da für handschuhe
wo sind denn die noppen
das hier geht so nicht die bänder müssen
doch angezogen sein
ich bin zwar auch immer so gefahren
die kinder in europa haben heute
natürlich ganz andere
trainingsmöglichkeiten die sind alle auf
kunsteisbahnen nach jedem lauf werden
sie mit dem wagen an den start gefahren
die haben ganz andere möglichkeiten wir
haben hier jetzt in sotschi eine moderne
bahn
aber stellen sie sich mal vor wie weit
das weg ist von hier aus
kann sich doch niemand hier leisten die
kinder dorthin zu bringen
das alles wird viel zu teuer sein
[Musik]
gastarbeiter marco messfahrt am fuße des
kaukasus in richtung sotschi geht weiter
mit allem was dazugehört
[Musik]
ich noch nie
den zwischenhalt auf halber strecke
machte bei dagestanischen freunden aus
einem dorf
gastarbeiter in einer russischen
kleinstadt
sie leben hier sehr einfach die
studenten
wir sind zufrieden so hier ist ein
geordnetes normales leben nicht wie in
pakistan wo sie einander erschießen oder
in die luft sprengen
[Musik]
dann hat es margret endlich geschafft er
ist in sotschi angekommen
[Musik]
es ist alles gut so die hauptsache ist
der arbeit
[Musik]
alexandra genießt die letzten stunden
mit ihrer familie
[Musik]
jetzt hat sie vier alles entscheidende
rennen in europa vor sich
[Musik]
was sie hier noch nicht weiß sie
scheitert und schafft die qualifikation
für sotschi nicht
[Musik]
im skigebiet von sotschi will man bruno
jelk auch während den olympischen
spielen als lawinen berater und die
selber gefällt es im kaukasus
trinken die skifahrer in der schweiz
alkohol
[Gelächter]
letztes jahr ist hier ein betrunkener
mit ihren in einen bahnangestellten
gefahren und hat ihn schwer am bein
verletzt
so etwas geht doch nicht
[Musik]
uns ist es auf jeden fall sehr angenehm
dass sich ja bei uns in russland sind
und die vorbereitungen für die spiele
begleiten
wissen sie wir sind sehr stolz darauf
dass wir jetzt so etwas bei uns haben
sie sind immer herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
über sinn und unsinn dieser olympischen
spiele haben auch wir uns viele gedanken
gemacht auf diesem weg nach sotschi
und kam am schluss auf ein oft zitiertes
russisches sprichwort das sind gemäss
sagt mit dem verstand kann beim russland
nicht begreifen mit herkömmlichen
maßstäben kann man es nicht messen an
russland kann man nur glauben
[Musik]